ich mache heute den anfang ich möchte
schon seit heute morgen darüber sprechen
und jetzt muss endlich 2015 gestern
abend habe ich erfahren dass in der
tabelle nach zwei geherrscht das
bedeutet also dass in der tafel wo
menschen hinkommen die auf das essen
angewiesen sind die zum beispiel rentner
sind die nicht genug geld haben oder
auch hartz 4 empfänger die können da
hinkommen in die tafel und für kleines
geld essen einkaufen dass es nicht mehr
möglich wenn sie nicht geimpft sind ich
habe mich gefragt was für einem land ich
lebe und ich gebe ich auch ganz offen zu
erzeugen morgen dort angerufen habe und
er mit erweitert sie mir gesagt hat dass
dort zwei geherrscht weil ich so
geschockt dass ich nach dem telefonat
erst mal geweint habe weil ich es für
mich persönlich wirklich schlimm fand
das nun menschen ausgegrenzt werden hier
geht es ja wirklich eines rechte
existenz wir können ja sagen wir
brauchen mehr impfstoff das ist nicht
mehr impfung das auch so vielleicht ist
zweig sogar auch in manchen orten ja
vielleicht brauchen wir das sogar auch
als gesellschaft aber was wir nicht
brauchen des menschen auszugrenzen und
ich möchte es mit aller härte sagen wie
können wir wollen dass menschen sich
nicht mehr lebensmittel kaufen können
weil sie nicht geimpft sind und es
trifft dieses mal die ärmsten der armen
für mich ist es furchtbar
also ich muss erst mal sagen dass ich
glaube dass die taffen eine ganz tolle
arbeit macht und wir sehen müssen was
die tafel ist und die tafel ist das
arbeiten ganz viel ehrenamtliche
menschen es ist keine hauptamtliche
struktur und deswegen glaube ich
ehrlicherweise wenn sie dort anrufen
dann sind die fast ein bisschen
überfordert dann auch die richtige
antwort zu geben doch nur ja geantwortet
und das ist auch tatsächlich bei ganz
vielen tafeln so bei mir zum beispiel im
wahlkreis haben die tafeln das so
organisiert dass dort auch eigentlich 23
gilt dh es kommen die kunden wie man das
bei der tafel nennt kommen rein und
werden versorgt und diejenigen die kann
nicht geimpft sind das sind
beispielsweise an der tafel in kirchheim
sind das von 50 stammkunden sind das 2
die machen eben vorher im test das wird
mit denen gemacht und dann können sie
rein und es wird bei anderen tafeln auch
ganz oft so gemacht dass man eben dafür
sorgt dass durch mehrausgaben nach außen
dann tatsächlich auch die betreut werden
also ich glaube deswegen müssen wir ein
bisschen mehr sagen mir schäbig schäbig
finde ich es nicht weil die
ehrenamtlichen
dort ihre arbeit machen werden
unglaublich gestresst auch in der korona
zeit und verhalten sich alles andere als
schäbig aber es zeigt natürlich einmal
mehr dass wir auch hier im bereich haben
der von kroner natürlich auch auf die
betroffenen möchte ich gerne antwort
denn natürlich habe ich sehr sehr viel
achtung für die ehrenamtlichen helfer in
der tafel und ich kann das auch
vollkommen nachvollziehbar menschen das
gefühl haben sie können sich gerade ich
schützen sie sind zwar geimpft aber sie
sind älter das ist nämlich übrigens die
antwort der tafel gewesen ein anderes
medium das die über 60-jährigen
freiwilligen mitarbeiter angst haben und
deswegen zweig eingeführt wurde
dementsprechend habe ich heute übrigens
auch eine e mail an die tafel
geschrieben da ist nicht weit von mir
weg und meine hilfe angeboten und die
junge union übrigens auch aus dem kreis
hat gesagt sie würden dort auch jetzt
helfen den 3g umsetzen kann
dementsprechend glaube ich man könnte
genügend helfer gerade finden die
gewillt sind es auch mit 3g zu machen
ich mag ich bewundere die arbeit der
freiwilligen helfer tag ich möchte die
tafel in keinem fall passion vor allem
es gibt ja ganz viele organisationen in
deutschland große hochachtung aber
dieses zweig finde ich trotzdem schick
ich finde es wirklich dass man bei
dieser organisation wenn man darauf
achtet wer da hin kommt das ist ja eh
schon erstmal ein weg dass man dort
hingeht viele fühlen sich nicht gut bei
dem weg und jetzt zu sagen du bist nicht
geimpfte bekommt nichts zu essen hier
ich finde das wirklich herrn wirklich
schwierig aber wir werden uns guten
punkt gemacht man kann natürlich auch
nach draußen sachen raus geben und das
ist etwas was mir in dieser ganzen
pandemie die diskussion viel zu selten
vorkommt einfach das bemühen was können
wir denn machen da kommt einer der hat
jetzt entweder seinen impfausweis
vergessen er hatte nicht oder er ist
nicht in vielen alltagssituationen kann
man den dienstleistungen irgendwie
zukommen lassen eben erwartet draußen
dann sagt er braucht kartoffeln und
milch und dann kriegt dann herausgegeben
und es funktioniert dieses dieses lösen
wollen das fehlt mir oft in der
diskussion und ich lese zu viel 2g 3g 3g
plus als verbot als ausschluss oder so
was wir sind ja oftmals sehr unentspannt
eigentlich kann man sehr vieles möglich
machen wenn man es denn will und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat es ja schon
2 g + + eingeführt also man braucht noch
einen pcr-test ist das weit im plus also
ich halt zweig in fast allen fällen
führt man aber leicht mit dem
kühlschrank verwechselt und der energie
also ich bin zwei generell problematisch
und ich finde es wird ein viel zu vielen
stellen verlangt und es spaltet
eigentlich immer wir haben es gerade
diese woche die untersuchung gehabt wie
unglaublich sicher noch zwei masken sein
können die also die rede die das risiko
sich anzustecken unter deutlich unter 1
reduzieren wir haben die möglichkeit
kostenlose bürger tests zu machen also
ich find zweig eigentlich fast immer
unangebracht es sorgt dafür dass die
leute zurück gedrängt sich fühlen es
schafft aggressionen auf beiden seiten
bei denen die sich ausweisen müssen bei
denen die die ausweise kontrollieren
müssen und wir haben wirklich die
möglichkeit leute zu testen christo
dieser regel durchaus wirkungsvoll ich
sehe also von unternehmen die sagen wir
müssen das machen obwohl uns das wasser
wirtschaftlich bis zum hals steht ich
sehe höre von gesellschaften von
familien die gespalten werden über diese
frage also ich fände wenn wir die
möglichkeiten haben abstand zu halten
tests zu machen masken zu tragen würde
ich sagen ist zweig eigentlich fast
immer eine große große schikane und bei
so einem fall für uns besonders traurig
aber in dem fall noch ganz kurz heute
kann auch die eilmeldung die habe ich
auf twitter bei dir gesehen mit dem
gericht wo ja auch zwei gemeinsame
glaube ich jetzt
leider sachsen ja ja das ist seit beginn
der pandemie interessanter effekt wir
hatten auch ähnliche urteile vom
verfassungsgericht sah man zum beispiel
das gericht gesagt haben es ist nicht
feststellbar ob es einen wirklich
kausalen zusammenhang zwischen der
maßnahme und dem zurückdrängen der
pandemie gibt das ist ja auch ein
ärgernis heran kann das vielleicht im
detail ausführen der politik dass
gerichte da stur ihre eigenen linie
fahren wobei ich das eben sehr schön
finde dass das macht eigentlich unseren
rechtsstaat aus dass man maßnahmen auf
ihre wirksamkeit überprüfen muss auf
ihre angemessenheit und auch
wirklich die die
zielführung ob man das wirklich damit
erreicht was man erreichen bilden und
wenn man riecht gerichtet da bedenken
haben ist das für die politik eigentlich
ein weckruf nochmal drüber nachzudenken
ob das in der fläche nötig ist ob es
gezielter möglich ist ob es andere
maßnahmen gibt oder ob man nicht
irgendwo auch nachlassen kann ich habe
manchmal
zufällig auch in bayern bei dem einen
oder anderen ministerpräsidenten dort
den eindruck dass der impetus der härte
irgendwie
eine tolle erfahrung ist und so viel
sicherheit auch ausstrahlt dass man die
psychologische wirkung da in den
vordergrund stellt
da bin ich anders gestrickt ich möchte
eigentlich dass der staat mir das
zumutet was unabweisbar ist und was du
wirklich zielführend ist man alles
andere über das ist ja
auch nicht so dass ich gerne sehenden
auges und eine gefahr oder eine pandemie
rinne freundlich ist ihre einstellung zu
2g also ich merke dass wenn man zweig
erlebt und durch die städte wie zum
beispiel hamburger innenstadt und sieht
wie die weihnachtsmärkte abgesperrt sind
da gibt es richtig gitter da sind die 2g
zugelassen und links gibt es die straße
für die sonstigen da merkt man plötzlich
aha unserer gesellschaft ist gespalten
und wenn man das einmal erlebt hat auch
mit familien die sich zum beispiel dann
trennen müssen weil einer darf dann da
drin gebrannte mandeln und der andere
nicht das geht aber so weiter mit
weihnachtseinkäufen dass familien so
gespalten sind weil vielleicht eine
nicht geimpft werden kann sodass man
einkäufe organisieren wer darf
eigentlich noch einkaufen man fasst sich
an den kopf und sagt ist das wirklich
gewollt oder ist der schaden nicht am
ende größer als der nutzen der
eigentlich damit weil aber in dem fall
wenn ich das vielleicht sagen dass herr
kessler in dem fall ist ja nicht die
politik die der tafel vorgeschrieben hat
sondern es sind die ehrenamtlichen die
für sich beschlossen haben hier führen
3g oder zweig ein weil wir es selber und
hier sind wir tatsächlich das schon ein
gewaltiger unterschied und das bedeutet
ja wenn die das nicht machen dann
verlieren wir die ehrenamtlichen die
diese strukturen auch in dieser harten
zeit tatsächlich aufrechterhalten das
ist mal das eines anderen
schülers ist mag vielleicht die wirkung
manchmal sein das so zu sagen was uns
auch treibt auch die entscheidungsträger
treibt und den bayern gibt es übrigens
nur einen ministerpräsidenten in dem er
dann hätte ich es so dann ist es so dass
vor allem die politik treibt tatsächlich
die menschen zu schützen und das ist
auch das was mein ministerpräsident und
parteivorsitzender tatsächlich jeden tag
in allen gesprächen die ich mit ihm auch
dazu habe was absolut im mittelpunkt
steht und ich glaube das ja auch das was
uns insgesamt 1 die frage ist dann
tatsächlich was hilft und wie und wo
ich glaube dass aber zweig insgesamt
eine sehr sehr gute maßnahme ist um in
dieser pandemie um dieser pandemie
tatsächlich zu begegnen es gibt
natürlich
entgegen stellen darf wenn man die ganze
politik nur noch durch das brennglas der
pandemie bekämpfung sieht dann wird man
ab einem gewissen punkt unempfindlich
oder fast sogar auf leicht blind aus
systemischen gründen für die opfer am
wegesrand also ich glaube es gibt
psychologische psychische folgekosten
die wir heute noch gar nicht ausmalen
können von leuten die die lebenslust
verlieren durch diese einschränkungen
von wirtschaftlichen existenzen die
kollabieren von lebensläufen die
abgebrochen werden weil sie nicht mehr
buchstaben sich raus trauen aus der
wohnung ich höre von familien den die
eltern zu ihren kindern sagen besuch uns
bitte nicht weil wir sind ja alle ein
gesundheitsrisiko und ich habe ein wenig
den eindruck dass manche teil der
politik und herr söder findigkeit leider
auch etwas zu dieser fraktion zugehörig
es übertreiben hat mit diesen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen ist vielleicht sogar
staat übertreiben mit diesen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen dass man also dort
wirklich diese folgekosten außer aus dem
blick verliert es gibt nicht nur opfer
dieser corona pandemie die wir
selbstverständlich entschlossen klug und
vernünftig und entschieden bekämpfen
müssen ist auch für mich klar aber es
fehlt einfach der blick darauf was es
mit den anderen menschen macht und was
es möglicherweise einen dauerhaften
sozialen schäden und zahlen auf den club
als mich grundsätzlich daran stört ist
eigentlich die haltung dass wir zum
start blicken und sagen staates schütze
mich und macht doch bitte was und wir
fangen dann erst an uns zu schützen wenn
der staat die regelung verordnet hat
also ich glaub ich glaube es hätte am
anfang der pandemie ein fenster gegeben
wo wir viel mehr in der selbstbestimmung
hätten reingehen können und sagen wir
machen zusammen wir fertigen wir genau
wir bewältigen zusammen die pandemie und
in den kommunen und in den haushalten in
den unternehmen entwickeln wir
strategien wie wir uns hier miteinander
schützen weil wir kennen uns hier vor
ort am besten aus und irgendwie sind wir
am anfang der pandemie in eine situation
gekommen wo ihr sagten so also bitte
liebe regierung schütze und bitte vor
dieser krankheit um unternimmt bitte
alles klappt das sehr aktuell
ich glaube dass
jedoch tatsächlich hinsehen das nicht
die bevölkerung reagiert wenn man ihnen
was sagt sondern leider so zu
selbständig aus der eigenen
verantwortung wenn es zu spät ist
nämlich dann wenn tatsächlich die
nackten zahlen auf einmal angst und
schrecken verbreiten und deswegen ist es
natürlich aufgabe der politik weil wir
uns tagtäglich damit beschäftigen wenn
wir sehen dass maßnahmen ergriffen zu
ergreifen sind bevor diese situationen
entstehen beispielsweise überlastung des
gesundheitssystems überlaufen der
intensiv kapazitäten etc etwas zu tun
das ist unser job und in der tat machen
uns damit nicht immer nicht immer
beliebt aber ich glaube es ist notwendig
und ich für mich habe ein gutes gewissen
liga eine kurze rückfrage fangen sie
alle maßnahmen gerechtfertigt in bayern
ausgangssperren ja also ich wollte nicht
sozusagen in der post betrachtung wenn
man danach weiß sozusagen welchen
welchen nutzen das hat kann man
sicherlich darüber nachdenken und sagen
war das eine zu früh zu spät wie auch
immer aber in der jeweiligen situation
war ich tatsächlich auch immer davon
überzeugt tatsächlich